156 países se han unido para garantizar
que todas las naciones del mundo tengan
acceso a la vacuna contra el coronavirus
al mismo tiempo el director de la
organización mundial de la salud hizo el
anuncio ahora en mixto hub subiré
nuestro objetivo es tener 2 mil millones
de dosis de vacunas disponibles para
finales de 2021 nos alienta a ver que un
gran número de países se inscriben en la
red de covas pero enfrentamos algunos
desafíos abrumadores para que esto
funcione según lo planeado debe haber
financiación y tertsch work aspland it
must be fund él
la lista de países que harán parte de la
red kóvacs incluye 64 naciones de
ingresos medios o altos que participarán
en la financiación de la vacuna entre
ellos los de la unión europea japón
australia argentina perú y colombia pero
los grandes ausentes son eeuu y china
el primero se desvinculó este año de la
ms una decisión tomada por el presidente
de donald trump mientras que los
funcionarios de la alianza siguen en
diálogos con beijing lado ms aseguró que
por ahora se han invertido 3 mil
millones de dólares sin embargo es
apenas una pequeña parte de los 35 mil
millones de dólares necesarios para que
tenga el impacto que se espera en perú
uno de los países más afectados por el
virus al tener la mayor tasa de
mortalidad por cada 100.000 habitantes
el presidente martín vizcarra aseguró
que el mundo entero debe tener acceso a
la futura vacuna
en esta lucha de forma efectiva
reconociendo a la vacuna y el
tratamiento contra este virus como
bienes públicos globales y asegurando el
acceso oportuno y equitativo a
medicamentos y equipos necesarios para
atender los casos de coronavirus en todo
el mundo han superado ya los 31 millones
de personas y el número de muertos se
acerca al millón